[Music]
refreshing and real a unique
underrepresented voice that leaves me
wanting to read more am I supposed to
know what that means
my mother she's a fan a fan of what
exactly your work and you how has she
read my work I may have sent her future
chapters you sent them to your mother
without asking me I was worried that you
would say no all the more reason for you
to ask they're not ready Lucas I'm still
working on them she's willing to send
them to a publisher she thinks that your
writing is that good
Lucas you can't just take someone's
writing and send it to whomever you
please I trust her opinion
do you trust mine yes of course but
that's not the point here
but this is what you wanted isn't it
I guess I shouldn't have sent without
asking but just take a look think about
it
Nathan and I had some words today not
pleasant ones I take it and then there's
Lucas what's going on with you
he sent the first three chapters of my
novel to his mother the book editor the
point is he didn't ask my permission
first
okay that was wrong but what'd she say
she said she liked them and she wants to
send them to a publisher Elizabeth this
is fantastic it is but but what but I'm
left wondering how much I can trust him
oh well that's not good
I mean the irony is Nathan seems to be
wondering how much he can trust me so
suddenly both of them have gone from
eligible to questionable
[Music]